it's it's of course it's misery inducing
it's it's anti-life we're living in i
believe an anti-life
ideology at the moment so
what can you do as an individual in that
situation
despair
really disbelief he's been reading a lot
of dostoy
that russian literature
too much russian literature will will
rot your brain this will tell you the
very sad truth about life
and you will never be happy again drink
vodka listen to sad russian folk music
and be done um
it was it was kierkegaard uh with with
despair which was and i only learned
this recently it's healthy to despair
because we stay stuck in an ideological
loop if we refuse to despair so if you
say no it's okay it's okay we're winning
the game
instagram is cool and i don't know tick
tock is great let's learn a tick tock
dance and post and get a million views
you're still stuck in the ideological
loop and kerekegaard was right you
should despair if it sucks you should
say it sucks but that's kind of a social
taboo for us like if something is really
awful and you want to say this is really
awful
it's a really fast way to become a
pariah it's a really fast way to get
even like criticism you guys lived it
you were like excuse me can we just
politely say that some of this doesn't
make much sense
big pushback for that big punishment for
that it's not
certainly in the beginning it's not a
rewarding experience until you find the
others and realize the support there
it's a lonely place to be in but despair
is key if we don't despair we can't
grieve
despair is essential to having an honest
authentic interaction with reality some
parts of life suck
we know this the vedic scriptures were
teaching us this 6 000 years ago all of
life is suffering the gnostics the same
thing this world is not perfect it's not
supposed to be so the horror i think
that we live in now is zizek has pointed
it out um is it's it's called the
fetishist split so we know that it sucks
and yet we have to pretend that it does
not and we have to stick a smiling face
on it that's torture you should be able
to say no this isn't very good i don't
like this this is not what i signed up
for and i'd like it to stop but we've
sort of been coerced into a position
where we feel like we can do everything
else but not that so despair i know what
you mean about that sorry just this
quick comment is because
i guess it's that thing of like the
first step to solving the problems
admitting you have one and if you admit
you have a problem it's quite right to
to be
at least dis dis whatever by that right
discontented yeah yeah yeah that makes
sense no
and i was gonna talk to you about not
only do we feel despair not only are we
forced to put on this fake smile and
project this happy life but because of
social media instagram that's what
everybody does so to use a terminology
of the time we're all being gaslit yeah
yeah into thinking that everybody's
having this great life apart from us and
that zizek would say that is ideology at
its purest
so where
we're feeding we're being force-fed the
ideology and then we force-feed it back
to each other because we're not just
being told what to desire our ability to
desire is being coerced so it's not just
what to desire it's the way in which you
desire it needs to be ideologically pure
as well so yeah we're all playing the
same stupid game for who
and it's it's this double bind it's been
fed back into it so it's plug backed
into itself we're all doing it for
somebody else but we all know perfectly
well it isn't true
uh it's nightmarish and the way out is
yeah you want to say it's you got it
somebody's got to go hang on
um this this sucks this is wrong let's
just
yeah i need to despair and really
despair despair is grief you go wow what
have we lost
[ __ ] hell we lost god we lost
community we lost each other look at our
children look at the state the world is
in this is horrifying
oh cry weep roll on the floor piss
yourself if you like i won't judge you
um but then
the morning after you say okay now what
now now i've accepted it's wrong now
what that's where we need to get to and
so i'm an accelerationist in that regard
but we're also incentivized not to do
that we're incentivized to
carry on because the more could you
carry on the more followers you have the
more followers you have the more
successful you are and the more
successful you are in this world the
more income you can generate blah blah
blah blah blah blah and is this not
capitalism so there's the capitalism of
of of acquiring likes acquiring it's
more i keep these bananas and what what
are they they're [ __ ] little digital
thumbs but our brains are so easily
tricked we think that that's a real
thing and so it's the acquisition of
more
keeps you in the game to actually step
out of the game is a huge social taboo
and it doesn't even need to be punished
or criminalized our brains will reject
it because you'd be like well everybody
else is doing this every other monkey in
my troop is doing it why am i going to
leave the tribe that's extremely
dangerous
you're jeanette i believe uh it's not
proven i personally believe your
genetics will fight you if you try and
leave the tribe because it's death
evolutionarily it's always been death
it's difficult so if you rebel and like
you were given your your story the other
day and these emotional highs and lows
and you've got to go off in a room and
cry
there's i think that's your dna saying
stop
it's safe over there don't [ __ ] do
this
um it's a hell of a fight it's a hell of
a fight it is but i also think there's
also a heroic thing in human beings
and part it is narcissism it's
narcissistic to think you're the person
who's going to go and change the world
but i do think there's a heroic instinct
in us as well which says
i know what's going on here yeah and
just because all these other [ __ ]
monkeys want to go along with it yeah
well i'm not one of you yeah i see
what's happening and i'm gonna step out
and i'm gonna say so and i'll take the
punishment yes i'll take the punishment
because i know what the truth is here
and the truth is this isn't working yeah
you can't have people running around
hashtag be kind while they mob people
into suicide yeah right that doesn't
work yeah so i i think there's also that
side of it as well which is
people it's a small minority of people
in society but they're the ones who've
always made history
you know what i mean 100
i i think the way you worded the
question before was like where have we
gone wrong and what we could do about it
and we said you got to bring back god or
at least some kind of reverence you have
to despair which means you have to be
able to tell the truth about what's
going on and then maybe you could have a
third thing there which is courage
and courage means not the big flex of
saying it and getting the applause for
it but the willingness to get hurt the
willingness to get [ __ ] up that's
courage if you know you're not going to
get hurt that's that's not courage if
you know you're going to lose your job
if you know you're going to be kicked
out of the
the comedy community that you're in
i don't know like for people who've not
done this they don't know how that fit
maybe they don't know how that feels
it's a it's an awful feeling i have
friends of yours people you've known for
years people you work with shun you
because you're telling the truth as you
see it it's it's that's that's despair
so you've already been through that one
we have you know there's a great scene
have you seen hunger it's a film about
bobby sands oh yes i have yeah yeah do
you remember there's this beautiful
scene in the middle of the movie where
the priest comes into the prison and
they're sitting and he and
bobby sands tell the story of how when
he was a kid they went on a field trip
and there was this deer that
that fallen in the river and it was
drowning and and he went over and he
knew what to do which is to finish it
off as it happened right
and he says i knew what i had to do
and i was willing to take the punishment
right
and i remember that scene always because
when we started trigonometry
i just felt the
the the catastrophe of where we're going
as a culture
is worth risking
the little that we had at the time yeah
to actually stand up against it and say
something
and the reassuring thing for me is
you know
that there's people out there who are
interested in hearing that there's
people out there who want to hear those
conversations and do something about it
you know 100 percent that scene that
you're talking about this isn't that
like a one-shot scene that goes on for
like 15 minutes yeah it's incredible
really good it's amazing
so you said the catastrophe
um i know that you're interviewing me
can i just ask you guys though how bad
do you think the catastrophe could be
how do how bad do you think a
prospective catastrophe could be in the
scenario we're in well actually i've got
a book no um i but i have i'm i have
written the book which is coming out
middle of next year which is called an
immigrants love letter to the west right
and my thesis is the the process we are
experiencing is
essentially
the destruction of western enlightenment
values
and
you know the existential stuff that we
talked about earlier that's that's
separate and probably even more
important but
i just know the way the world actually
works right and
people in the west can have this airy
fairy nonsense about how equality and
diversity that's not how the rest of the
world works the rest of world works on
very simple basis if i'm stronger than
you then i'm going to take over you
right that's how it works so the moment
the west undermines itself there are
plenty of people waiting
to fill that void that power void and
china maybe russia they'll come in and
if you think racism is bad now mm-hmm
what do you think i'll show you what it
means
what it means that's my view
what about you francis uh
for my background as being a teacher the
thing that i despair about the most is
what we're doing to our children
what we're doing to our kids you see
with transgender ideology the fact that
we give puberty blockers to
eight-year-old six-year-olds and somehow
we think that this is progressive and
kind is an abomination it's child abuse
and and the
the reason that we're not allowed to
have sex with children is because
children can't consent it's that it's
that simple and they can't consent to
take puberty blockers because they have
no concept of consequences that is a
psychological fact
the fact that we hand them social media
smartphones from the age of 10 and 11 is
abuse as well because you were just
essentially
molding their brains in the most
unhealthy way possible you're showing
that the most unhealthy images possible
what instagram does to young girls and
to young women i don't think i think
it's the tip of the iceberg we're going
to see an absolute slew of girls who
have go with a variety of body
dysmorphia anorexia etc etc the fact
that instagram are trying to create an
instagram for kids have you heard about
this no i haven't they're trying to
create a specific instagram for kids
it's just vile and we're going to reap
the rewards and i find it that i find it
sad because it's not their fault
and we're going to have a generation
that is stunted as a result 100
yeah what do you think
gulags and genocide we're on the road to
it and i people laugh they're
not here i'm like what do you think
we're special do you think historically
we're [ __ ] unique um i know you've
had douglas murray on a few times but i
remember he always said when people are
saying oh this is this is a racist
country it's like well try going to
another one we can show you
re i lived in malaysia if you want it i
mean it's not a terrible place but if
you want to see
institutionalized racism if you're not a
muslim malay you're in a different tax
band and there are different
universities oh absolutely different
universities you go to different
employment laws apply to you and you
cannot convert to be it's called boomi
putra you can't convert to it it's
ethnic it's in your blood it's and you
are in a different tax band so it
doesn't matter how many chinese and
indians are working to help boost their
economy which they are the majority uh
earners there doesn't matter they're in
a separate
that's racist
like what we're talking about in this
country
is
i mean specifically that's institutional
racism that is in it's enshrined in law
if it's not enshrined in law
where it's going to be difficult for us
to prove that so to the douglas murray
point as i he always says compared to
where
or compared to who how are you grading
us how are you grading our civilization
but i think on the path we're on is
gulags and genocide why do you say that
people will look we didn't laugh because
it's not funny anymore austria
segregating vaccinated people from
unvaccinated people something we would
never believe would have happened to you
i mean to be fair though those boys do
have a history for it you do a little
yeah it's austria and bavaria
get in the camp we don't want your
freedom
but
it's not funny anymore really because
this is this is why the shadow point
that you made right at the beginning is
so important
it's only people who truly understand
their own capacity for evil
and their own capacity for social
conformity and their own capacity most
importantly for being
in in love with their own virtuousness
because that's what the nazis thought
that's what the communists and the
soviets saw they thought they were
fixing society and of course it's worth
putting a few a few you know
non-believers in a camp of course it is
because we're creating the the future
brilliant society in which man will be
perfected and it's only when you know
our listeners and you know jordan
peterson obviously has talked about this
a lot
it's only when you know that you are
capable of putting people in a camp that
you might not
you know but why do you say that is your
fear why do you say that's where
potentially going i i'm geographically
and historically literate and i'm not a
[ __ ]
when i'm looking around and i and i look
at like
the i know that um you're moving away
from talking about the woke movement a
little bit which which i understand um i
was woke i was a radical leftist when i
was a student i had the purple hair and
the eyebrow piercing and all that
studied feminism as well as the
psychology and i understand that i
understand where where these people are
coming from but as it goes through its
different iterations it's like a
photocopy of a photocopy of a photocopy
and i was about well let's not bully
people let's keep people included let's
be inclusive so my thing was like let's
be reasonable and not
excessively tyrannical
and let's not have a policy of the devil
take the hindmost because i've been the
hindmost and i didn't like the devil
taking me let's try and support people
fine
then it goes through these different
iterations like a virus that's mutating
over time
to something that is utterly moronic i
mean
moronic you would have to be a [ __ ]
idiot to believe that this was useful
and we're talking psychological
illiteracy emotional illiteracy
geographical literary
illiteracy and historical literacy the
the soviets and the nazis that we're not
talking about 400 years ago there's
people still alive
she lived on
half her family were
purged in the soviet thing and then the
other half of family were taken as
slaves to germany during the war she's
alive you can go talk to her perfectly
accomplishment and you you've got
relatives from venezue
so
we we can't just go oh we have 400 years
to go the spanish inquisition
we've got no no no no i'm sorry we're
the same people we just have smartphones
now we're not better
and we and you could say well we've
learnt our lessons
i'd love to see the evidence that we've
learned our lessons because we seem to
be doing some eerily similar things
again
aren't we going back now to
neo-segregation
we only just gave it up 40 years ago and
we're doing it again why because it
worked so well the last [ __ ] few
times we did it so that that's why i i
just look at
what i try to say is how does it begin
obviously everything escalates once you
sort of open the the floodgates a little
bit then another one then another one
then another one yeah google ads and
genocide we are guagging people we've
digitally gulagged people how far away
is that from actually gulagging them so
now physical goo lagging
as you just said it's going to take
place in austria and the czech republic
which i was living in up until
six months ago that's doing it for
monday as well they're following in
austria's footsteps as they usually
really yes from monday the sudan land
will be visas i'm telling you
the germans doing it as well uh yeah
they're talking about it are they really
[Music]